here it is 82 pages of facts and figures
for anybody who likes modeling the
economy post breaks it and there are a
range of scenarios here going from the
hardest of no deals in which we have
extremely hard restrictions on EU
workers coming into the country and that
is at its worst north of a 10% hit on
long term growth now what are we talking
about here is a 15 year horizon of how
the economy grows and what is saying is
that the worst prediction is that the
economy would be ten point six percent
smaller at the end of that 15 year
period than it would otherwise have been
the most optimistic is that it would end
up only being naught point six percent
smaller and that is if you assume with
the continuation of tariff free access
to Europe and movement of European
workers so there are a great range here
the most optimistic were based largely
on the white paper that the government
put forward back in July were the one
thing though that the document doesn't
really do frankly is take into account
recent events even if you look at the
checkers model it's quite hard sort of
work out exactly what would be the
economic impact of that and if you look
at the withdrawal agreement that mrs.
May is of course trying to push through
the Commons now well that isn't in here
at all so if you extrapolate I think you
come to somewhere around between two and
a half and three point nine percent hit
on the economy under the terms of that
withdrawal agreement at the end of the
fifteen year period as you said
disparities about which industries are
really hit pharmaceuticals and
automotive under the terms of a No Deal
brexit both reducing in size by more
than 20 percent interestingly if you
model most optimistic one they actually
stay exactly the same size there isn't
one industry networks electricity that
would grow just a little bit under the
terms of that kind of brexit but the
critics are going to say well these
numbers are outdated as you rightly so
faisal people
we'll already say that this is part of
project fair others will say that this
is further proof of the economic damage
that the country faces particularly if
it were to go down the road of a No Deal
praxis